hey this is preshtalwalker
here's an email i received slightly
edited for presentation in this video
hi i'm chunny a senior high school
student in the philippines grade 11
big fan of yours on youtube
can you please solve this
i'm curious about the smallest number
for which all numbers 1 to 100 are
factors of that number
i assume it has 25 or more digits
i know the method to solve the problem
which is
i've removed this part of the email as
it would spoil the puzzle
but my calculator cannot handle such a
large number
can you solve it thank you
i did some research and i found the
answer online and the number actually
has 41 digits
the number is pronounced
69 duodecillion 720 undecillion 375
decilin 229 non-alien 712 octillion 477
septillion 164 sextillion 533
quintillion 808 quadrillion 935 trillion
312 billion 303 million 556
800.
this is a very special number
and the puzzle for you
what is the prime factorization of this
number
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
in general finding the prime
factorization of a large number is a
computationally difficult problem
so we're going to solve the problem
using elementary number theory
the number n is the least common
multiple or lcm of all the whole numbers
from one to one hundred
so n is the product of the highest power
of the primes
from one to 100
this ensures that every single number
from 1 to 100 whatever its prime
factorization is
all of those prime factors will be
included in n
so we include every prime number that's
less than a hundred
we also need to account if there are
repeated prime factors
in order to do that we find the highest
power of each prime that's less than a
hundred
for example two to the six is equal to
sixty-four
so we need six factors of two in n
now one more factor of two two to the
seventh would actually be larger than a
hundred it would be 128 so we do not
have seven factors of two
then we have three to the power of four
is equal to eighty-one
the next higher power would be higher
than a hundred
we have 5 squared is equal to 25
7 squared is equal to 49
and then the next prime 11 square is
larger than 100
so we don't have two factors of 11
every other prime that's larger than 11
will have a square that exceeds 102 so
we're done checking for repeated prime
factors
so these are all the prime factors that
are in n
so we can then write n is equal to the
product of all these prime factors
raised to the highest power that's less
than 100
that's 2 to the power of 6 3 to the
power 4 5 squared 7 squared
and then all the other primes 11 13 17
19 23 29 31 37 41 43 47 53 59 61 67 71
73 79 83 89 and 97
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description
you can also support me on patreon and
catch me on social media either at
mindyourdecisions or at presh talwalkar